they they said you're letting Brittany  do a whole apology tour look it okay  guys let's take that premise let's say  Brittany  that's what she's trying to do she's  trying to grift Rebrand all of that  stuff let's just let's just go to the  extreme anyone who takes her seriously  that says more about the interviewer  blah blah blah  I'm thinking about the next generation  of women  if if she has had mistakes that she  regrets now even if it's a fake regret  to be a whole apology to a rebrandt all  the stuff you guys said why why not let  her be public and let the people see  and they can make the decision for  themselves why not let the next  generation of women know this is what  city girl culture becomes like the and  it could be fake it could not be genuine  I don't know you know  um  it seemed  genuine to me but again I don't know